we are seeing a revolt by house
republicans against their number three
leader in the house
that's congresswoman liz cheney she's
daughter of former vice president dick
cheney
she is under fire big time from gop
members for opposing
former president trump house republican
leader kevin mccarthy was overheard
yesterday suggesting
that he no longer supports her in fact
his words where i've had it with her
nicole killian is on capitol hill
covering the story nicole why is this
happening now
well gail these tensions have been
building for months
over former president trump's role in
the republican party
just this week gop conference chair liz
chaney blasted the former president over
his claim that the 2020 election result
was a big lie she also
voted to impeach him after the
insurrection leader mccarthy has
defended mr trump
and visited him at mar-a-lago earlier
this year he
said members are concerned about her
ability to carry
out her job and the party's message if
they want to win the majority next year
in a hot mike moment he went further
i think she's got real problems i i've
had it with
i've had it it's you know i've lost
confidence
a cheney spokesperson tells cbs news
this is about whether the republican
party
is going to perpetuate lies about the
2020 election
and attempt to whitewash what happened
on january 6.
liz will not do that some gop lawmakers
are already pushing for new york
congresswoman and trump ally elise
stefanik
to take over cheney's position in house
republican leadership
a vote to replace cheney could happen as
early
as next week if she is ousted it would
send a clear signal
about the direction of the republican
party and how far it's willing to go
to back the former president and his
false claims which
many gop voters still support anthony
nicole killian at the capitol thanks
nicole